[Music]
good afternoon everyone my name is David
County honored serving and Democratic
congressman and my great pleasure to
welcome all of you to the 16th 2015
miserable and course history and
biography stage which is generously
sponsored by Wells Fargo we at the
Library of Congress are extremely
thrilled to be presenting the National
Book sessile for the 16th time this
terrific event would not be possible
without the friends that we have
supporting us generously supporting like
Wells Fargo and we are very appreciative
that but more important we would not be
here but for readers like all of you who
support the authors are interested in
them and really come out in droves and
so we're extremely excited thank you
very much for being here today okay
thanks
this year's festival is inspired by
journeys and the idea that a book is a
voyage unto itself taking us to places
that we might not be able to see in
person but we can visit by reading about
it and it gives us the opportunity to
better understand our world and in
particular why we are here today
celebrating histories and biographies so
reading to us is an ideal form of travel
and it's really the best way for us to
develop and encourage and grow our minds
in addition to the author presentations
that we have here on this stage for you
today we have lots of other events I
hope you will take the opportunity to
visit the lower level of the Convention
Center where we have lots of family
activities we have booths for our
sponsors
AARP Wells Fargo we also have the
Library of Congress pavilion where I
will encourage you to visit us and learn
more about your national library learn
all about the wonderful things that we
are doing at the Library of Congress to
make our treasures available to you
whether you come and visit us in person
or visit us online so we have a great
lineup I don't want to take up too much
time and so you I hope you will welcome
our first presenter who will things
offer us mr. Carlos lazada who is the
associate editor and non Vic nonfiction
book critic for the Washington Post I
invite him to come up and introduce our
first speaker thank you very much and
enjoy your day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon welcome to the 2016
National Book Festival David mentioned
my name is Carlos asada I review
nonfiction for the Washington Post which
is a charter sponsor of the festival
thanks again to the Library of Congress
which has hosted the festival since for
16 years as well as festival co-chairman
David Rubenstein and many sponsors that
make the event possible I've never met
Sara Bell personally until right now
but maybe like a lot of you I feel like
I've known her forever whether through
her work on this American Life her
delightful books into the side alleys of
American history and in the role that
most excites my moody six-year-old
daughter as the voice and soul of violet
from The Incredibles Sara can basically
do anything and make it seem effortless
and funny and profound all at once and
if you've not read her obituaries of
John Ritter and Tom Landry you really
you're missing out but we here to talk
about her books she's written the
history of Hawaii of the Puritans of
presidential assassination sites and
most recently a book on America's
revolutionary BFF
the Marquis de Lafayette in her 2015
book Lafayette in the somewhat United
States there will be time for questions
after Sarah speaks and c-span is
covering the history and biography
session so be on your best behavior
Sarah will be signing books at 1:30 so
please get one it is my huge fanboy
pleasure to introduce Sarah Val
[Applause]
[Music]
hello-hello book lubbers people of
c-span I realized recently that I travel
around the country so much and I only I
only meet people who read books and I
don't know if you watched the news like
the last year or so but I would like to
say that I'm cool with that
but I thank you that I like my little
vision of America that I get from
meeting all of you so I'm feeling very
contemplatively if you're watching this
on television we are here in Washington
DC and for me I arrived in this city
precisely half my life ago 23 years ago
a wait for a second for you to do the
math I know that's not your strong suit
or mine you have other nice qualities so
23 years ago I arrived in this city on
the train from Montana my parents drove
me up to Shelby Montana where I caught
the Amtrak I took it across North Dakota
that took a while changed trains in
Chicago saw the buildings of Louis
Sullivan thought I want to live here
someday I ended up doing that went
across Pennsylvania I remember the
conductor we were passing the
Susquehanna River and he said get a load
of this scenic Wonderland and I arrived
here in DC for my Smithsonian internship
and I think it was the next day Yasser
Arafat shook ribbons hand on the White
House lawn it was a hopeful time in
America the Library of Congress is
sponsoring this event you know when I
was an intern at the Smithsonian the
first works that I worked on that had
the the ISBN number the library of
congress catalog number were finding
aids to things like art in philadelphia
and then at me i'm archives of American
Art or yeah that was the main one
Italian American art history so I was
saying earlier that for me as an author
every time I get one of my books when it
comes in the mail the first time the
first thing I do is look at that catalog
number because as we all know life is
short in the Library of Congress
is forever
so take that Great Britain but anyway
being here you know thinking about when
I was you know a young cop leaving home
to come here I realized that is the
story that I've been writing all these
years through seven books it's always
the story of the misfits leaving home
and and and that is the story of our
country I think earlier this year in
this city t-bone Burnett said this is
the story of the United States a kid
walks away from home with a song and
nothing else and conquers the world so
for me that is always the story I'm
writing whether it's Theodore Roosevelt
leaving New York City to mourn his wife
and mother and head out to North Dakota
to be a cow man and you know as one of
his biographers said he was the only
president who ever read Anna Karenina
while on a three-day search for cattle
thieves or our friend Abraham Lincoln
who when he left Springfield to come
here as president and took the train to
Philadelphia to Independence Hall and he
you know he said that the political
sentiments I entertain has been drawn
from the sentiments which were given to
the world from this Hall and he said
that the goal of his presidency was to
save the country invented there and he
added ominously I would rather be
assassinated on this spot than surrender
it obviously the person who did
assassinate him is another misfit who
left home from Baltimore you know
and then I've written about you know New
England missionaries who come to Hawaii
like so many Turkey folk of the early
19th century who saw the new maps from
expeditions like that of Captain Cook's
and resolved to spread the gospel to all
the places where cooks sailors had
spread the clap or to their forebears
the New England Puritans such as the
Massachusetts Bay Colony - unlike those
hippies from Plymouth were trying to
convince the English government that
they were not separating from English
and that they were going to America
where they would remain as English as
beheadings and clotted cream and and
even wrote a letter to Charles the first
in 1630 called a humble request in which
they said they just wanted to remind the
King II that we shall be in our poor
cottages in the wilderness
whereas in private John Winthrop their
leader would tell them we will be
opposite we shall be as a city upon a
hill so misfits leaving home my latest
misfit leaving home as a French teenager
the Marquis de Lafayette and this book
tells the story of him leaving home and
his pregnant teenage wife to come to
America to throw in with George
Washington's Continental Army and so
I'll read for a bit men I'll take
questions and I wanted to read the
section of when he come of his voyage to
America and his early time and then I'll
read a little tangent about a heroic
bookseller to pander to the subject of
the proceedings
so it's 1777 Lafayette has absconded to
American he's brought his own ships to
come here the king of France is trying
to keep him at home is why family is
trying to keep him at home because as I
mentioned she is pregnant and once he
makes it onto this ship he has purchased
across the Atlantic he starts sending
his wife he starts writing his wife
Audrey and these letters to try to
explain why he has abandoned her and
their forthcoming child I believe I say
in the book that while history might be
full of great fathers recorded history
is not where to find them at sea La Fea
unveiled the grandeur of his mission to
his wife Adrienne and attempted to
include her in it he wrote I hope that
as a favor to me you will become a good
American she is a teenage French
aristocrat from one of the most
illustrious families in France she lives
in a mansion in Paris when she isn't
living at their mentioned in Versailles
so asking her to become a good American
is sort of baffling also he really
wasn't in a position to ask her any
favors nevertheless
they proclaimed to his wife the welfare
of America is intimately bound up with
the happiness of humanity he is going to
become the deserving and sure refuge of
virtue of honesty of Tolerance of
equality and of a tranquil Liberty to
establish such a forthright dreamland of
decency who wouldn't sign up to shoot it
a few thousand Englishmen just as long
as mister being wasn't one of them
alas from my end of history from our
inner history there's a big file cabinet
blocking the view of the sweet-natured
republic Lafayette foretold and it is
where the Gov
it keeps the folders full of Indian
treaties the Chinese Exclusion Act and
NSA monitored electronic messages
pertinent to national security which is
apparently all of them including the one
in which I asked my mom for advice on
how to get a red sharpie stain out of
couch upholstery I've confided in his
wife in coming as a friend to offer my
services to this intriguing Republic I
bring to it only my frankness and my
goodwill no ambition no self-interest in
working for my glory I work for they're
happy disregarding the inherent
contradictions of proclaiming his lack
of ambition and self-interest in the
same sentence he revealed that attaining
glory was one of his two stated goals he
was an only child
the phrase coming as a friend glows on
the page because it turned out to be the
truth it's appropriate to ding Lafayette
for the casual cruelty with which he
abandoned his family roll the eyes a bit
at his retro quest for fame or Envy his
outlandish optimism but none of that
negates the fact that he turned out to
be the best friend America ever had and
I'm not only referring to as youthful
derring-do on battlefields up and down
the eastern seaboard I am also referring
to any number of his dull grown-up
kindnesses later on such as assisting
Thomas Jefferson the United States
minister to France in the 1780s in
opening up French markets to American
goods my advance lobbying procured
procured Nantucket whalers the contract
to supply the whale oil that lit the
streetlights of Paris because of
Lafayette the city of lights glowed by
New England boiled blubber and to say
thanks for getting him and to say thanks
for getting them the gig all Nantucket
rallied its milk cows to send him a
giant wheel of cheese
what's gratitude what's so American
listen cheese to France okay
so finally after his two-month voyage on
his ship the victory which he called a
you know floating on this dreary plane
they came ashore in Charleston around
midnight on June 13 1777 waking up the
household of major Benjamin huger of the
South Carolina militia and that's where
they stayed and Lafayette a wrote later
I retired to rest that night rejoicing
that I had at last attained at the Haven
of my dreams he went on to gush the next
morning was beautiful everything around
me was new to me the room the bed drapes
and delicate mosquito curtains the black
servants who came to me quietly to ask
my command the strange new beauty of the
landscape outside my windows the
luxuriant vegetation all combined to
produce a magical effect in other words
it was a buggy swamped chock full of
slaves the Lafayette was in love so he
and his men they basically they start
out in carriages and then into the
horses and by the end they're basically
like walking to Philadelphia where he's
going to what became Independence Hall
and you know to announce Here I am and
you know he expected a warm welcome the
moment Lafayette recalled was peculiarly
unfavorable to strangers I don't really
- that at all
the Americans were displeased with the
pretensions and disgusted with the
conduct of many Frenchman's consequently
he wrote the Congress finally adopted
the plan of not listening to any
stranger so when Lafayette and his
friends called at the Statehouse then
the moniker of Independence Hall
Congressman James level of Massachusetts
chewed them away snarling it seems that
French officers have a great fancy to
enter our service when
out being invited but most of them
including Lafayette had been invited by
American agents in France
hence the throngs of Earth's and
Frenchmen who had been washing ashore
for months expecting to be welcomed with
rank and riches so also I should mention
at this moment Europe is
uncharacteristically at peace and so all
of these European officers especially
Frenchmen come over in droves wanting a
job and Washington who is always in need
of men wasn't excited about these
particular men because he said they have
no attachments nor ties to the country
and Hiba moans they're ignorant of our
language and he pointed out that
American officers would be disgusted if
foreigners were put over their head and
so that's exactly what happened right
before a lot that arrived this other
French guy his name was really Dooku
drei and he was a French veteran of the
Seven Years War and he showed up in
Philadelphia months before Lafayette did
saying Here I am I'm you know a bigwig
at Lincoln paraphrasing a bigwig at
Louis of the sixteenth Court and I'm the
greatest renowned authority on artillery
in France and what he was was a wine
merchant son who had maybe seen a few
cannons and but he shows up and he says
I I deserve to be your artillery chief
and so it turns out that replacing the
Continental Army's beloved chief
artillery officer Henry Knox was not as
easy and arbitrary as bewitched casting
a second Darrin because Henry Knox was
the revolution born in Boston in 1759 to
Irish immigrants Knox dropped out of
school to support his mother and
siblings after his father's death and
princessing at a bookbinder and he
eventually opened his own bookstore the
London bookstores and after the coercive
acts of 1774
this was really hard on pretty much all
the colonists but especially its
merchants and especially Knox as a
bookseller they had closed support and
he couldn't get any of the books he was
selling from England and you know the
colonists were boycotting stuff from
England anyway so those acts of the
intolerance they were supposed to serve
as a warning to all the other colonies
and meant to slap Massachusetts into
submission and but what happened was it
further radicalized
and already radical Massachusetts and
rallied the other colonies to come to
its material and political aide so Henry
Knox
meanwhile he had wooed the royal
governor's daughter Lucy Flecker
great name and he had joined a local
monition militia the Boston grenade
years and then shots were fired in
Lexington and Concord in 1775 so Knox
leaves his you know failing bookstore in
the hands of his brother throws in with
the militias then when Washington is
appointed the new commander-in-chief of
the Continental Army and he shows up and
he you know he's telling the soldiers we
should have no more sectional rivalries
we're all one country when privately you
know he's writing to his crony back in
Virginia these people are stupid
especially the Massachusetts men you
know it's still a work in progress
but then and at that time you know
Boston was a was under siege
the British had occupied the peninsula
across ttan and their Navy controlled
the harbor and they were just
resupplying the cities with provisions
shipped down from Canada this is this is
me these are the maps I'm drawing in my
mind I just assume you can see them
so the Patriots with the Patriots had
them surrounded but they to break the
stalemate they needed weapons and and
then they got the good news that
Ethan Allen and Benedict Arnold and
their people had captured Fort
Ticonderoga where there were all these
all this artillery cannons and mortars
and howitzers you know 300 miles away
and Henry Knox the book sellers you know
he's like 26 I think at this point he
goes up to Washington says how about I
go get all them weapons and 300 miles
away and Washington's like yeah sure go
ahead
bookstore owner and and he and he did it
he and his brother Henry Knox and his
brother set off for New York in November
I think it was and then by January they
had returned with 43 cannons 14 mortars
and two howitzers dragged across frozen
rivers and over the snowy Berkshire
Mountains by oxen on custom sleds this
is the derivation of that old Yankee
proverb that if you can sell a book you
can move 60 tons of weaponry 300 miles
in winter and then you know Washington
like has all the artillery moved up on
the hill of Dorchester Heights and then
the British wake up and see all these
cannons pointing down at them and they
promptly hightail it to Canada and
that's how Henry Knox became the chief
artillery officer of the Continental
Army he got the actual cannons he
actually got the artillery and then he
trained on and recruited all the other
artillery officers so everybody liked
him and thought he was doing a pretty
good job and so when this French guy
shows up and says I'm your new artillery
chief there was a big flip out amongst
the men and officers of the Continental
Army and so that's sort of the you know
that's a that's the environment that
Lafayette walked into
luckily the French guy had the decency
to he and his horse were crossing the
delaware river and he drowned the horse
lived so everything was fine and and
then it's a win-win you know so that's
what Lafayette wife walked into I'm the
thing is the reason that the colonists
especially their leadership to Congress
and Washington and his highest-ranking
officers are in this weird position with
the French and all of these French
noblemen Lafayette included is all they
want to do you know because they're
basically they just want what any
self-respecting terrorist wants they
want to become a state-sponsored
terrorist and they're just waiting for
the king of France to give them money
and guns and support and his army and
his Navy and that's house they won the
war eventually so they they take
Lafayette on because Ben Franklin since
this letter you know like this again I'm
paraphrasing this kid is a really big
deal be nice to him I'm haven't finished
shaking down the French government and
so so they make a Lafayette a
major-general
that's what he is called he's basically
a glorified intern until he proves
himself and then you know so he gets
finally he gets his commission and then
a few days later he meets George
Washington and
you know Washington was you know six
foot four inches tall and he
historically makes a big impression on
Lafayette Lafayette was so starstruck
when when he meets Washington he wrote
it was impossible to mistake for a
moment his majestic figure and
deportment nor was he less distinguished
by the noble affability of his manner
which is a sweet memory but it does get
on my nerves how easy it is for tall
people to make a good first impression
unfortunately because of a scheduling
mishap
we can't be at Kareem abdul-jabbar's
presentation next door I'm just going to
go out on a limb and say everybody loves
Kareem abdul-jabbar
I do love Kareem abdul-jabbar so anyway
he he joins up and Washington he slowly
you know grows on Washington because
he's just so gung-ho Washington all the
whole war all his men are deserting in
droves and here's this kid this French
kid who's just the whole wars like put
me in coach and and when Washington you
know says okay you can join my military
family which was lingo of the day to to
basically Washington is saying okay you
can become one of my minions you know
like the way I'm Alexander Hamilton was
described as a member of Washington's
military family but remember Lafayette
isn't he was an orphan and when
Washington said family he meant Shammi
minions but what Lafayette heard was son
then you know hijinks ensue
so I guess I will take some questions if
you if you have them there are these
microphones set up here yeah let's get
cracking
hi I was wondering when I read the book
if you'd seen the show Hamilton and what
you thought about the portrayal of
Lafayette she didn't hear that the
question was about Hamilton have have I
seen Hamilton and why do I think that
the portrayal of yet I've seen Hamilton
I obviously loved Hamilton even though
there's a so much Hamilton in Hamilton
obviously the last you know we would
love the Lafayette in Hamilton is
Lafayette who was just a publicity [ __ ]
and you know the fact that he has you
know so comes out so charming and
chivalrous and and is such a good dancer
with such wonderful hair a lot Bant was
already going bald at 19 you know there
was last time I saw it there was a an
empty seat in front of me and for some
reason I just kept picturing Lafayette
in it and he I mean he you know he was
just have been swooning the whole time
and it's interesting though like one
thing about that show especially because
of the casting and the this wasn't it
went your question but I have been
thinking about it later lately because
people have some qualms about the
founding fathers especially the ones who
owned other people and there are some
people lately who want to disregard all
of their accomplishments and I can
understand that
but one way you get past that is make
Washington black which I'm definitely
doing next time
such a good idea we should have done
that that's that should have been our
original casting Washington should have
been black yes
yeah in today's I guess the mass
recording that goes on everybody's lives
is so archived how do you think that
will affect our look at today's events
as a historian how do you think that
will change everybody's lives today are
so archived right just with like
television the social media everything
is out there and like very intimate
thoughts are posted for everyone to see
how do you think that would affect your
job as a historian looking back or how
it would change um I mean I guess the
NSA is archiving a lot of stuff right I
mean it's my bread and butter a lot in a
lot of these books is letters you know
like letters on paper that you have to
put on white gloves to look at I think
if things are being saved then that's
good and I mean one thing about that
well I think you used to future
historians is that for better or worse
people nowadays are pretty forthcoming
about everything you know like sometimes
it's really hard to figure out like what
Washington was thinking I mean his wife
burned up almost all their letters upon
his death and they're a little cagey and
tactful and they leave out private
things because those are private I guess
one advantage of this world we live in
how people are documenting every omelet
and
aspect of their day I'm guessing I'm not
on social media but I hear the jokes
about it
I guess that would be helpful especially
if there was some kind of social
historian where your job was to figure
out what people ate all you have to go
it's like look at all these food blogs
and Twitter and everything and you could
see you know like oh people here a lot
of goat cheese I don't know but I mean
they're instant but I think because
communication is so constant there's
maybe less of that grandeur you know
like if I'm like George Washington was
painfully aware of that everything he
was doing it was basically especially as
president that he was inventing the
presidency and so he he wrote these
letters with such care too you know he
was writing to the person but he's also
writing to us to posterity and you know
I don't really do that when I'm just
emailing my friend Sherm so I think like
with the letters because they were more
formal but also you got the best of
these people you know and maybe we're
not always at our best in our electronic
communication I'm not yes I Sarah I'm
with the American friends of Lafayette
we're 400 strong I wouldn't people yeah
thank you for bringing our hero to the
forefront I appreciate you very much oh
that's all that's why I did it I know I
know
I would have done it for free Iowa we
bought your book so he sometimes
laughing gets criticized for being doing
things for the glory of it not for the
not for the why the reason the purest
reasons back in the 18th century was
that such a bad thing doing it just for
the glory just for the glory um no I
don't think so I mean if we're going to
condemn all historical figures who you
know may who accomplished their
accomplishments because what they wanted
was glory that wiped out everyone maybe
mother Teresa but she got a lot of press
too you know I mean if you're doing good
things I don't really care what your
motives are that much I mean there is
something about Lafayette he's such a
boy no I mean he's 19 and I mean it is
kind of bad form to abandon your
pregnant teenage wife there's a so I
can't overlook those things what I mean
the his glory that was part dislike his
a quest for glory was part of what
fueled his accomplishments and one of
the reasons he was so valuable to
Washington and the American cause was
that he was so gung ho he was so brave
he you know didn't care about his own
personal safety when he was wounded at
the Battle of Brandywine he was supposed
to be recuperating but he you know gets
up wraps his bum leg in a blanket and
rides back to the front and I mean he's
kind of reminds you of like what Lincoln
said about Grantland is like for
Washington like he needed him he fought
you know so all of that glory whoring it
had a very very practical outcome you
know it wasn't just that he wanted the
glory and he certainly loved it and when
he came back as an old man in 1824 I
mean he just loved it was just a love
fest for over a year of people talking
about how much they loved him and so
happy it was back so yeah he wanted
glory but he you know he did say in
Hamilton immigrants they get things done
he got things done you know his glory
was based on achievement it was based on
spilled blood and sweat and you know the
old college try
it wasn't like getting glory for I don't
know a what do people get glory for now
it has to do with Twitter I think not
that that is an accomplishment but you
know what I mean like oh dude thank you
very much yeah hi hey there
okay so you've written a lot about
historical folk heroes and also about
our American rogues and it seems like
you tend to enjoy the life of the rope
more the life of the wet the rope the
rogue yes I was a rogue the one going
out on the road history's bad boys yeah
uh-huh or girl right I was just
wondering if you had a favorite oh if I
have a favorite of anyone I've written
about I mean roads yeah I mean that's
what I was saying at the beginning I do
write about the misfit I have the soft
spot for a lot of them even the
unlikable ones maybe especially the
unlikable one you know I was I I
subscribed to the digital Washington
Post and I'm sure if all of you do you
woke up to an email from them as you do
every morning and that said the headline
was is she likable not true they were
talking about
but I'm in my opinion likeable can be
kind of overrated and one of my favorite
people to write about was Roger Williams
who was a Puritan theologians likeable
already right and he's come to Boston to
the Massachusetts Bay Colony and they
offer him the job of being the minister
in Boston which as Puritan jobs go
that's the one you want
and he turned them down because he
basically he found them not puritanical
enough and he they kicked him out of
Massachusetts basically because they
just wanted him to calm down about
religion the Puritans wanted him to calm
down about religion and he's just this
annoying person who was constantly
hurrying them and so they boot him out
and he another misfit leaving home he
goes to Rhode Island and founds Rhode
Island and for a lot of non
hippie-dippie reasons basically
establishes freedom of religion in Rhode
Island not because he he thinks
everyone's beliefs are valid but because
he feels like pretty much everyone
except for his wife is going to hell for
what they believe and maybe that should
be punishment enough
and so everyone the Rhode Island becomes
this bastion of misfits Jews Baptists
Quakers you know so like Roger Williams
he thought the Quakers had the right to
live there he spent one time he spent
three days debating them to the extent
that I think they wanted to kill
themselves but meanwhile you know back
in back home in Massachusetts Quakers
are actually being hanged on Boston
Common so he's a very weird unlikable
annoying person but I I found him
sometimes hard to like for very easy to
love you know so people can do great
things and maybe you don't want to have
lunch with them
thank you yes yeah I love reading the
books for the history and then I love
off of the side John she take to places
like Bruce Springsteen's boy at home he
and what you learned and then the
correspondence and all that you delve
into and I was wondering if when you
were like writing people like Lafayette
and Winthrop do you think of it do you
know what themes what their theme song
would be like get that in your mind when
you that what's our theme song yeah
beware if you could give them a theme
song not together I mean I don't know
about that but like generally the books
have theme songs for me like this one
for some reason I always wanted to put
on a Pete Seeger's version of Oh
Shenandoah you know for summers in it
like it just it it like adheres to the
like that passage I read what Lafayette
thinks America is going to be like
there's something in the way he sings
that song like that's the country that
they were trying to build and that's the
one I would like to live in when I was
writing about the Puritans I had I had
three songs that I would always put on
because they were you know leaving home
and they had these ideals and one of
them was the was it oh the Mormon
Tabernacle Choir subversion of bound for
the promised land you know there was a
Chuck Berry promised land and
Springsteen's promise live because it
was all about it was not what they were
doing it was all about promise in the
future and it had these kind of biblical
overtones yeah yes hello I love the dirt
of history especially George Washington
the dirt is that way I said yes the dirt
of history mm-hmm George Washington the
hero of Fort Necessity whoo go George
you know he was overall a marginal
general he meant he himself was officer
corps so what influence did Lafayette
have
on him what influence did rocket have on
Washington without Lafayette metallo
Yorktown's a whole nother story I mean I
think one I mean for one thing
Lafayette just bucked up for Washington
for most of the war Washington was about
to get fired
sometimes for cause you know the
Lafayette was always on his side and
whenever you know these conspiracies
arose to get rid of Washington Lafayette
was the one saying like these people are
idiots you're one for the ages so there
is that I think it was just like keeping
Washington going and like Washington
keeping going was kind of the key to
that war like just his endurance just
putting up with it sticking it out and
so I think there was that influence also
lucky it was a pretty fervent
abolitionist and while and so I he could
have influenced Washington's decision to
have some of his own slaves Washington
to have some of his own slaves freed
upon his death there's thought about
that but I would say mostly it was moral
support so I don't know if you have a
friend like that who whatever when
you're down there the one he bucks you
up I think that's - luckily it was for
Washington's I only have time for one
question because someone else is coming
in here next we you you to which one do
you think has the better question
he says you have the better question
that makes me want to hear his question
but you can tell ask me your question
after which I just have to litter
physically remove myself from this
podium okay
yes you talked about lovely it's coming
back to America in 1824 a little bit
about the reason why almost every city
in America at that time name something
after Lafayette what impact did he have
on America that yes yes and yeah in fact
um great question to end on I made the
right choice thank you
yes when like it came back in 1824 and
25 that that 13 months victory lap
around the country where he went to all
of the states that is the origin for how
all these states and not States but
cities and counties and warships and
horses and babies and streets and parks
got named after Lafayette and I think
speaking in Washington DC is worth
remembering that the most meaningful of
any of these no offense to la Paix at
Ronald Hubbard is Lafayette Park across
from the White House because this is
kind of our capital of protest this is
where we other people go to yell at our
presidents and I mean I was getting
about Lafayette being an only child but
one of the most only child things he
says was and we'll forget the context
because um we don't have time but
Lafayette said I did not hesitate to be
disagreeable to preserve my independence
and so I think Lafayette Park or left it
square cause it's also called embodies
that spirit and even though we beat our
beat ourselves up in this country for
how much bickering there is how we can't
get along I think it's that is annoying
and time-consuming but it is also the
source of our greatness and the fact
that we have this place across the
street from our head of government house
where people as George HW Bush said
would like beat those damn drum
while I was drying out dinner I think
this is something that we as a people
and you and your city should be enormous
ly proud of and I think the fact that
it's named after Lafayette I think I
think that would probably be to him his
greatest honor but and I think it is too
good night
[Applause]
you